WILL COME TO ORDER WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT --
WE DO NOT QUITE YET HAVE A
QUORUM --
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND LET ME JUST SAY THAT TODAY
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT DAY WITH
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE LIVER
COMMUNITY --
AND THERE'S NO PLACE I'D RATHER
BE THAN IN THE LABOR COMMITTEE
BECAUSE LABOR FIGHTS FOR WORKING
PEOPLE.
IN THE STATE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
ARE RESILIENT PEOPLE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR WORKING
PEOPLE IN THIS STATE AND IN THIS
COUNTRY AND SO WE ARE PROUD --
TO CHAIR A COMMITTEE THAT BEARS
THE NAME OF THE PEOPLE OF LABOR
CONTINUE TO FIGHT STAND
SOLIDARITY ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE LABOR --
IT SO WILL GET UNDERWAY --
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH --
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY THREE FOR
SENATOR MITCHELL --
WE ARE READY AT WHEN YOU ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE ON THIS TO BROWN.
ON AND MISTER CHAIRMAN I WAS
GLAD I WAS IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO HEAR YOUR REMARKS BECAUSE I
COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
MEMBERS TODAY OPPOSITE IN SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY THREE WHICH
REQUIRES THAT EMPLOYERS WITH
FIVE OR MORE EMPLOYEES PROVIDE
TRAINING ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TO NON SUPERVISORY
EMPLOYEES.
THE WAY THAT NON SUPERVISOR
EMPLOYEES ARE CURRENTLY INFORMED
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ESTHER POSTER.
BUT THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE TRAINING TO NON
SUPERVISORY EMPLOYEES.
A TWENTY TWO THOUSAND ONE STUDY
FOUND THAT EVEN A THIRTY MINUTE
TRAINING SAID RESULTED IN
PARTICIPANTS BE MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT HARASSMENT
THAN THOSE WHO HAD NOT
PARTICIPATED IN THE TRAINING ALL.
WE ARE SENSITIVE TO THE DELICATE
BALANCE BETWEEN BUSINESS COST TO
EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS EMPLOYEE
SAFETY IN THE WORKPLACE.
WE'RE WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
WITH VESTED INTEREST TO DRAFT
LANGUAGE THAT WILL ENSURE
TEMPORARY AND SEASONAL EMPLOYEES
WHO MAY BE AT A HIGHER RISK OF
HARASSMENT.
ALSO BE PROVIDED TRAINING.
I'M GLAD TO HAVE WITH ME TODAY
GINNY NANCY FOUNDER AND CEO OF
HIM TRAIN.
AND EVAN GOLDBERG REPRESENTING
STATE COMPTROLLER BETTY WHO
SPOTS IN THIS LEGISLATION.
GREAT.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL --
AGAIN MY NAME IS JAMIE AND SEE --
I AM A TWENTY PLUS YEAR LAWYER
SPECIALIZING IN THESE ISSUES OF
OF PROVIDING WORKPLACE
HARASSMENT.
BY SEEING THIS ISSUE FROM ALL
SIDES I EVER PRESENTED EMPLOYEES
REPRESENTED EMPLOYERS.
I'VE BEEN AND I'VE EXPERIENCED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT MYSELF A FEW
TIMES EARLY IN MY CAREER.
OF ALL WHICH LED ME TO START.
IT IS CURRENTLY A 45% CULTURE
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY PROVIDING
ONLINE EDUCATION ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BIAS IN ETHICS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT UP
LEVELING PEOPLE'S UNDERSTANDING
OF SKILLS.
OF THOSE TOPICS HELP GRAY
HEALTHIER WORKPLACE CULTURE.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO PERHAPS COULD
CONFINE MY MY COMMENTS TO FIVE
POINTS --
TODAY AND STARTING WITH.
WHY S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
WILL MOVE US FORWARD
[inaudible]
SO.
I THINK THAT IF WE WANT TO
CREATE RESPECTFUL WORKPLACES
WHICH IS I THINK A TERM USED IN
THE CURRENT GOVERNMENT CODE
CALLED NINE FORTY SUBJECTION QUE
WERE ALL OF US HAVE ALL
EMPLOYERS HAVE AN OBLIGATION FOR
RESPECTFUL WORKPLACE.
VAN MANDATING HARASSMENT
TRAINING JUST FOR THE
SUPERVISORS IS NOT ENOUGH TO GET
A ENOUGH CRITICAL MOMENTUM TO
ACTUALLY CHANGE THE CULTURE
RIGHT SO THE MANAGERS ARE
TYPICALLY ONE FOURTH OF AN
ORGANIZATION --
AND YOU HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
OTHER EMPLOYEES THAT YOU'RE NOT
YOU'RE NOT INFLUENCING YOUR NOT
AFFECTING.
PLUS THOSE EMPLOYEES THE NON
MANAGERS ARE THE ONES THAT
TYPICALLY NEED THE SUPPORT THEIR
LAST THEIR LESS EMPOWERED
THEY'RE USUALLY MORE JUNIOR --
LESS SAVVY LESS INFORMED ABOUT
THEIR RIGHTS AND LESS EMPOWERED
TO EFFECTUATE THEIR OWN
SITUATIONS SO THOSE ARE THE
FOLKS THAT REALLY NEED THE
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE --
OF A PROGRAM LIKE EDUCATION AND
AND GUIDANCE ON THESE ISSUES
[inaudible]
ALSO.
PROVIDING EDUCATION TO THOSE
EMPLOYEES IDEALLY SHOULD JUST BE
TAILORED TO THEIR NEEDS SO
MANAGERS HAVE A WHOLE SEPARATE
SET OF OBLIGATIONS.
OF REFLECTING THEIR MANAGERIAL
DUTIES AND THAT'S WHY IT AB.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE MANDATED TO
OUR PROGRAM.
AS EMPLOYEE YOU NEED A LOT LESS
THAN THAN THAT INFORMATION AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUGGESTING A
ONE HOUR PROGRAM TAILORED TO
THEIR NEEDS.
SECONDLY S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE IT WILL EXPAND THE THE
TRAINING MANDATE. TO EMPLOYERS
WHICH JUST FIVE EMPLOYEES --
AND CURRENTLY IT'S EMPLOYERS
WITH FIFTY EMPLOYEES AND I THINK
THIS IS HELPFUL BECAUSE THESE
SMALL BUSINESSES THE EMPLOYERS
WERE JUST FIVE EMPLOYEES UP TO
FIFTY ARE USUALLY THE ONES THAT
HAVE LESS STAFF --
AND LESS PEOPLE ABLE TO CREATE A
PROFESSIONAL ENVIRONMENT --
AND SO.
THE EMPLOYEES OF THOSE
BUSINESSES ARE USUALLY THE ONES
THAT ARE MORE VULNERABLE.
BECAUSE THERE'S LESS STAFF
THERE'S LESS PEOPLE TO CREATE A
PROFESSIONAL ENVIRONMENT AND
EIGHT EDUCATING GUIDE SO BY
DOING -- A
MANDATE THAT THAT APPLIES TO
MORE EMPLOYERS I THINK THAT YOUR
SURVEYING AND SUPPORTING I FELT
VERY LARGE DEMOGRAPHIC HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
COUPLE OTHER POINTS CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS.
A ON AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE SO
CURRENTLY THE THE LAW MANDATES
HARASSMENT TRAINING OF EMPLOYERS
WITH FIFTY OR MORE EMPLOYEES --
THE SUPERVISORS OR MANAGERS TWO
HOURS OF INTERACTIVE CONTENT%
EVERY OTHER YEAR.
I WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT DOESN'T WORK ABOUT
THAT -- SO
UNFORTUNATELY OVER THE LAST
DECADE OR SO.
THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY HAS
LARGELY TAKEN A DEFENSIVE
POSTURE WITHOUT AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS THEIR INTENT.
IN ALL THE PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
THAT NEED HAS LARGELY BEEN
DRIVEN BY A NEED.
TO REDUCE OR MINIMIZE CLAIMS.
AND YOUR INTENT USUALLY DICTATES
THE OUTCOME YOU GET.
AND SO BECAUSE THE ATTACK HAS
BEEN EMPLOYER DRIVEN TO REDUCE
OR DEFEND AGAINST CLAIMS YOU'RE
NOT GETTING.
AN UP LEVELING OF SKILLS AND
EDUCATION.
WHAT IS CHANGE IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT I THINK WHAT'S
CHANGED IS DEMOGRAPHICS AND
SOCIAL MEDIA?
SO I SAY DEMOGRAPHICS.
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN WELL
REPRESENTED IN THE POWER
STRUCTURE OF ORGANIZATIONS.
FEELING MORE AND MORE
COMFORTABLE TO SPEAK UP.
AND LESS TOLERANT OF BAD
BEHAVIOR.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE SOCIAL
MEDIA SO THAT ANYONE AN
ORGANIZATION WHO IS COMFORTABLE
SPEAKING UP CAN NOW EASILY SHINE
A LIGHT ON BAD BEHAVIOR.
SELL LESS TOLERANCE FOR BAD
BEHAVIOR AND MORE VISIBLE
VISIBILITY INTO BAD BEHAVIOR.
LASTLY WHAT WORKS --
IN THE TEN PLUS YEARS THAT --
I'VE BEEN IT AND TRAIN WORKING
WITH WORK FORCES IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE WORK WITH ABOUT A THOUSAND
WORK FORCES IN CALIFORNIA --
MIDSIZE WORK FORCES ALL THE WAY
UP TO FORTUNE FIFTY WORK FORCES.
AND REGARDLESS OF THE SIZE AND
INDUSTRY VERTICAL THERE ARE
THERE ARE A FEW COMMON
DENOMINATORS IN TERMS OF THINGS
THAT DO WORK.
SO WHAT TYPICALLY WORKS IS
GENERALLY GOOD QUALITY CONTENT --
TYPICALLY.
ILLUSTRATED BY ARE FOCUSED ON
GOOD VIDEO SCENES --
SO STORIES IN VIDEO SCENES
REFLECTING CURRENT EVENTS THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN THE NEWS
THINGS ARE HAPPENING --
AN EVERYDAY KIND OF COMMUNITY
THAT PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE THE IDEA IS.
YOU NEED TO GET FOLKS IN THE
WORKPLACE TALKING ABOUT THESE
ISSUES.
THERE THERE ARE OFTEN NOT EASY
BLACK AND WHITE ISSUES ARE OFF
OFTEN SHADES OF GRAY.
AND SO YOU NEED TO EDUCATE FOLKS
AND UPPER LEVEL THEIR SKILLS TO
TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
AND IN ADDITION YOU NEED TO
PROVIDE.
LEARN OUR INTERACTIONS SUCH THAT
PEOPLE CAN LEARN FROM EACH OTHER
AND LEARN FROM THE COMMUNITY
RATHER THAN PASSIVELY JUST HERE
A ONE SIDED EMPLOYER MESSAGE
THAT.
OFTEN DOES IT RESULT --
IT IN.
IT L. N. UP LEVELING SO --
ALL AND ALL I THINK THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE IDEAL OF GETTING
PEOPLE UP LEVELED --
TO A POINT WHERE THEY'RE
EDUCATED IN AND AND AND ABLE TO
CREATE HEALTHY WORKPLACE
CULTURES WHICH I KNOW IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS IDEALLY WHAT WE WANNA MODEL.
THANK YOU IT TOOK A MOMENT TO
ESTABLISH THE RUN A NATION.
THAT'S A VERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THURMAN AYE ARE HERE.
I'M READY TO GO.
THURMOND HERE LAURA --
BONTA.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
THE BUS STEINORTH COR MISTER
THANK YOU FOR THE RECORD IS A
MEMBER BONTA WILL BE FILLING IN
JUST A DAY FOR SEVEN MEMBER
LORENA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THOSE BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED AT
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON SEAMUS WITH
GROWING UP SEEING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SARAH FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT MAKE YOU.
ANGELIQUE YORK NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT.
TRACY SELLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION TO
THE BILL AND PRINT BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF ON OUR ONE REMAINING
CONCERN AND RELATED TEMP WORKERS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
REACHED A SOLUTION AND WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO GOING FULL
SUPPORT ON THE BILL ONCE THOSE
AMENDMENTS ARE IN PRINT.
AND LASTLY WE JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE OFFER AUTHOR FOR
THIS PROACTIVE APPROACH TO YOU
ENSURING SAFE PARAFFIN FREE
WORKPLACES THANK YOU ALL THAT IN
ONE BREATH THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF ANGLED OVER
STATE COMPTROLLER BETTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU YOU.
FUTURE MEMBERS OF MARKETS THAT
WHILE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL THIS ASSOCIATION LIKE
ALLY MY COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE ARE
ALSO A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
POSITION.
THANK YOU COUPLE IN BETWEEN
ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON SUPPORT
XIN GUZMAN ON BEHALF THE
TEAMSTERS' SIDE AFTER THE
EIGHTEEN YOU MACHINIST AND
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION HERE --
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HE EVEN COME FORWARD IT IS SO I
DON'T KNOW THIS ANY REALLY QUICK.
FOR I MEAN I'M I'M I'M ACTUALLY
[inaudible]
SEMI TWEENER.
THE KALRA ICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURESAND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE WERE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED BUT WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION AND I
WANT TO PUBLICLY STATE THAT ON
THE RECORD. TO COMMAND THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US IN RESOLVING OUR ISSUES
SO WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO REMOVE THAT OPPOSITION TO
HAPPY TO THANK YOU.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION OR SOME OTHER
DECLARATION OF NEW FOUND SUPPORT.
BUT MICHAEL MILLER THE COPPER
CESSATION OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING FOR ITS
REMOVAL OPPOSITION VERY SOON OUR
LAST ISSUE AS MUCH THAT CAN HURT
WITHOUT FROM OTHERS THE
TEMPERATURE SITUATION THAT
AGRICULTURE YOU HAVE.
FROM THE RECOUNT TRACTORS LAST
WEEK PASSED US BETWEEN NINE FIVE
COULD THE TOUGHEST TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS IN LAW AND DO WHEN
WHICH THAT WE DON'T HAVE SOME
OVERLAP WITH THAT AND WORKING
VERY MUCH WITH THE AUTHOR.
SPOTS WITH BAKER THE AUTHOR THE
SPONSOR'S STAFF AND HOPEFULLY
RESERVE WILL REMOVE PROPOSITION
VERY SOON THINK ABOUT A
DOWNPAYMENT TOWARDS FUTURE
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO OFFER --
OPPOSITION OR A POSITION IN
BETWEEN --
SEEN NONE WILL TURN TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
SEEN -- NINE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
JUST SAY I MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE WORKED --
DILIGENTLY WHAT THE MANUFACTURER
THAT EVEN IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT I TALKED ABOUT HAVING
HEARD --
CONCERNS WITH REGARD TO BRING
SEASONAL EMPLOYEES TING YOU TO
DO THAT --
TO TO SEE IF WE CAN GET TO A
PLACE OF AGREEMENT FOR ALL AND I
IN THE MEANTIME I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO ALLOW US TO KEEP THE
VEHICLE MOVING.
SO WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND FOR YOUR WORK --
WITH -- SOME
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS TO HELP THEM
GET TO A POSITION OF SUPPORT --
ENDOWED WITH THE FOR TO SEEING
IT MOVE FORWARD ARE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
OF THIS AS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA AIKENS PARA BONTA JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA REMUS
STEINORTH [inaudible]
SOME COME.
IT YOU NEEDS ONE MORE TO GET OUT
WILL BE THAT WILL OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOUR
* IQ.
UP NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR BRADFORD
WHO IS HERE TO PRESENT S. B..
FOURTEEN TWELVE I'M WELCOME BACK
TO LABOR SENATOR BRADFORD WE'VE
ALWAYS ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOU
IN YOUR CHAIR AND WE'RE GLAD TO
HAVE YOU BACK HERE IN THE HOUSE
A LABOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT.
SB --
FOURTEEN TWELVE IT'S SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT EMPLOYERS SHOULD
USE BACKGROUND CHECKS TO SCREEN
PEOPLE.
ONLY FOR RELEVANT --
EXPUNGEMENT.
SPONSORED SHOULD SAY CONVICTIONS.
SOME EMPLOYERS AS WE KNOW GO FAR
BEYOND WHAT THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS SHOULD --
BE AND I USE THOSE EXPUNGED --
CONVICTIONS ARE RELEVANT FOR
EXCLUSION ARE DENYING --
EMPLOYMENT --
THIS COMPLETELY UNDERMINES TO
REHABILITATE OF GOALS THAT WE'VE
SAT IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM --
WHEN THIS BILL LEFT THE SENATE?
WE HAD FIVE ORGANIZATIONS WHO
OPPOSE IT.
DO DO WE SHOULD HEAR WOULD ONLY
ONE A WE HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY.
AND EVERY FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
SEVERAL ONE HAS IN AGREEMENT
THAT.
THIS IS A GOOD COMMONSENSE BILL
THAT THEY CAN LIVE AND WORK WITH --
ALSO WILL TAKE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AT THE FIRST
OPPORTUNITY THAT WERE REMOVED.
EVEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL AS WELL WE HAVE
THAT COMMITMENT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT --
A PANDERS TO PROCEED OUT FEDERAL
EMPLOYMENT OR STATE EMPLOYMENT
ROSE AGAIN.
STRAIGHT.
FOR ITS KNOW --
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW THEY
STEAL THOSE CRIMES THAT ARE
STILL EXCLUDED BY FEDERAL LAW.
OF THIS BILL DOES NOT SUPERSEDE
THAT OUR INSTITUTIONS STILL CAN --
DO BACKGROUND CHECKS ON THIS IS
SUPER.
EMPLOYERS ARE GOING BEYOND WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT LAWS WHEN
WE TALKED ABOUT EXPUNGEMENT IN A
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND ON THAT
NOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
YOUR ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON M. EMILY CHILD ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND THE OTHERS WISHING TO SPEAK
AND TO SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION ON
THE MEASURE PLEASE COME.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTINA'S
BAGNOLI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
I'M.
SAYING I WELL YOU GUYS KNOW THAT
WE HAVE NO AND OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION --
I THINK THAT THIS IS A WELL
INTENDED BILL --
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT'S
A TIMELY ISSUE --
AT BOTH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL BY I'M I THINK FEDERAL
LEVEL IS THE KEY WORD HERE
BECAUSE THERE ARE CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS WE NEED ADJUSTED IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH.
THIS BILL IF IT'S IMPLEMENTED.
I'M.
WERE THE BILL ITSELF REMOVES OUR
ABILITY TO PULL A FULL
CONVICTION HISTORY.
AND ALSO AFFIRMATIVELY REMOVES
OUR ABILITY TO CONSIDER PRETRIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAM WHICH IS A
REQUIREMENT OF THE FDIC.
I'M.
EXCUSE ME I'M ALWAYS OUT OF
BREATH --
ARE.
OUR REQUIREMENTS I IT REQUIRES
US TO NOT HIRE FOR CERTAIN
CRIMINAL OFFENSES INVOLVING.
DISHONESTY BREACH OF TRUST YOUR
MONEY LAUNDERING MORE
DISAGREEING AGREED TO ENTER
ENTER PRE TRIAL DIVERSION.
OR SIMILAR PROGRAM IN CONNECTION
WITH THE PROSECUTION FOR SUCH
OFFENSE.
AND SO --
BASICALLY --
WE FEEL THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLY WITH OUR FEDERAL
REGULATOR --
THE FDIC HAS STATED IN BOTH
THEIR CURRENT AN* UPDATED SO
P. THEIR STATEMENT OF POLICY.
I'M AN EXAMPLE OF OUR DUTY IS
TIED TO OBTAIN A LISTING OF ALL
CONVICTIONS AND PROGRAM AND
TREES.
I'M I'M GRAVE CONCERN OF OURS IS
RECENT LITIGATION THAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THIS AREA.
A WITH FRANK NO NORI VERSES VIVI
VIVENT I'M BASICALLY IN THE
ARGUMENTS IT WAS.
ASSERTED THAT LABOR CODE
[inaudible]
WITCHES I WHAT THIS BILL IS
WRITTEN UNDER WAS VIOLATED.
I THE PLAINTIFFS PLAINTIFFS
CLAIM ALLEGED THAT THE DEFENDANT
VIOLATED CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE
BY ASKING FOR S. OR SEEKING FROM
ANY SOURCE INFORMATION ABOUT
PRIOR.
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS.
WE'RE FEARFUL THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S CURRENTLY TO GAZE XIN
THAT'S BEING DECIDED NOW I THAT
IF THIS BILL SIGNED INTO LAW
WE'RE GOING TO STEP BACK INTO
THE EXACT SAME THING.
AYE BECAUSE THE BILL AMENDS --
PARAGRAPH AM.
I WHICH I IS A SECTION THAT I
ESSENTIALLY I GIVES A CARVE OUT
THE FULL CONVICTION HISTORY.
I THAT IS WHY WE PROPOSE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE PROPOSED
WE'RE THE ONLY EMPLOYERS
OPERATING UNDER THE LAWS OF THE
FDIC THAT ARE OPPOSING THIS BILL --
AND HAVING REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION WERE REGULATED BY
THEM AND WERE PENALIZED A
MILLION DOLLARS A DAY FOR
VIOLATING --
SECTION NINETEEN AND SO WE DON'T
WANT TO BE IN A GOTCHA SITUATION
WHERE WE FEEL LIKE WE HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL LAW.
BUT THEN WE'RE VIOLATING STATE
LAW.
AND SO --
THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
IT'S OUR MOST IMPORTANT CONCERN
AND WE REALLY NEED THAT SMALL
ISSUE FIXED WE BELIEVE.
THAT SENATOR BRADFORD CAN STILL
HAVE A BILL THAT AFFECTS ALL
OTHER EMPLOYERS.
ON THAT DON'T HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THE CERTAIN REQUIREMENT
FROM THE FDIC.
THANK YOU DIGITAL.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
RECENTLY WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION ORIGINALLY HERE JUST
THAT OFFER TECHNICAL ADVICE BUT
THE BILL ESSENTIALLY FORCES A
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL VIOLATION OF
LAW BECAUSE IT IT BASICALLY SAYS
THAT IF YOU'RE AN EMPLOYER.
YOU CANNOT PULL FULL CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK BUT FOR
PARTICULAR CRIMES.
WELL CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
WORK VERY MUCH LIKE COLLEGE
TRANSCRIPTS WHEN YOU WANT TO
INQUIRE ABOUT INDIVIDUALS --
EDUCATION BACKGROUND YOU DON'T
GET TO ASK THE COLLEGE JUST GIVE
ME THE GRADES FOR CHEMISTRY YOU
GET A FULL REPORT OF THE ENTIRE
TRANSCRIPT.
OF THAT TIME IN COLLEGE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS WORK THE SAME
WAY WHEN WE ASK THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ROOM FOR REPORT WE
GET ALL CRIMES.
BY VIRTUE THE FACT WE'RE GONNA
GET ALL CRIMES WERE GONNA BE
VIOLATING THIS BILL BUT THERE'S
NO OTHER WAY TO CHECK WHETHER OR
NOT SOMEBODY HAS BEEN CONVICTED
OF THE CRIMES OF THE FDIC SAYS.
THERE WE CAN'T HIRE FOR SO SO
ULTIMATELY IT WAS AN EMINENTLY
REASONABLE AMENDMENT THAT WE ASK
FOR WE ASK SENATOR BRADFORD.
LET'S PUT AN AMENDMENT THE BILL
THAT SAYS YOU HAVE A SAFE HARBOR
IF YOU RECEIVE A FULL BACKGROUND
CHECK BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY YOU CAN GET --
ONE BUT YOU CAN ONLY CONDITION
EMPLOYMENT.
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE FEDERAL
REGULATOR SAYS THAT YOU CAN'T
HIRE.
FOR IT WAS A IT'S A REASONABLE
AMENDMENT BUT WAS REJECTED.
SO IT FORCES A TECHNICAL
VIOLATION YOU'RE IN RECEIPT OF A
FULL REPORT YOU VIOLATED THE
BILL.
BUT THAT'S ONLY WITH THE DOJ
ISSUES FOR THE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
PURPOSE THINK.
THEY DO OTHERS WISHING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE.
PARKER DOESN'T HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE IN OPPOSE LOS MINUTE
POSITION BY IT FOR THE SAME
REASON STATED BY THE PACKERS
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU.
TRACY SELF ON THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WERE LISTEN OPPOSITION IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT DO YOU WANNA AND
STRESS THE FACT THAT WE WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION AND
BOEING NEUTRAL.
ONCE AND THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AT THE AUTHOR AND
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED ARE AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR IN A STAFF ON THIS
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MAKE YOU.
ORGAN MARKETS DEL I WITH
CALIFORNIA STATUS.
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL THIS
ASSOCIATION SIMILARLY WE WILL BE
REMOVING OPPOSITION I LIKE TELL
AYE MY COMMENTS OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SWITCHING TO
ADD ON OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
[inaudible]
BOX [inaudible]
AND DUBBED.
CAROL MCINTYRE WITH THE CABLE
COMPANY CAME TO ME AND SAID.
DATA AT SOME FCC REQUIRE WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THAT
BECAUSE SHE SHE STUCK WITH THE
THE INTENT OF THE BILL THE
REASON THE BILL GOT AS FAR AS IT
DID.
AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION BECAUSE SHE WORKED
WITH MAKING SURE THAT WE
PROVIDED.
PEOPLE WHO HAD CRIMINAL RECORDS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVIEW.
BEFORE --
SOMEBODY BROWN FILED IT THROUGH
THEIR THEIR APPLICATION TO
TRANSFER HIS ONCE THEY SEE.
THAT YOU'VE BEEN CONVICTED OF A
CRIME ON BETA EVEN GIVE YOU.
A FIRST CHANCE LAST US A SECOND
CHANCE AND AND SO OF OF WE WORK
TO SIMPLY BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY FEAR.
YOU DOING CABLE AND YOU'RE
YOU'RE.
THEIR SEX OFFENDER RAPIST WE
DON'T WANT YOU GOING IN AND
PUTTING CABLE.
AND PEOPLE HOMES AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK THROUGH A LOT OF
THAT KNOWING THAT THE ULTIMATE.
PURPOSE OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO -- WAS
NOT TO BE IN VIOLATION OF ANY
FEDERAL RACE BUT MOST IMPORTANT
HOW DO WE GET PEOPLE INTO THE
JOB MARKET.
AND SO CAN YOU GET AND LISTEN TO
THE PARK CAN KIND OF WALK US
THROUGH HOW YOU SEE.
THIS WOULD WORK THROUGH --
SOMEBODY THE CITY OF ALL COLLEGE
CHALLENGE OF HOW DO YOU SEE IT
WORKING THERE THEY'VE BEEN ABLE
[inaudible] TO TO TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS OR HOW
THIS BILL.
THE HOME WORKS WITH OUR DOESN'T
[inaudible]
CODE GONE.
IN OPPOSITION.
I THINK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND
I THINK YOU TOUCHED UPON IT ON
THIS BILL IN NO WAY SUPERSEDES.
FEDERAL REGULATIONS WHAT THE
BANKS HAVE TO DO IN REGARDS TO
FELT WERE REGULATIONS OF
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN THOSE --
CONVICTIONS THAT EXCLUDE
EMPLOYMENT IT DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING.
ALL WE'RE SEEING JUST LIKE AS
YOU STATED.
LET INDIVIDUAL HAVE OPPORTUNITY
TO INTERVIEW LET THEM MAY HAVE
BEEN MADE A AS THE LARGEST
CURRENT LEGISLATION STATES.
HAVE A CONDITIONAL OFFER OF
EMPLOYMENT AND THEN DO THE
BACKGROUND --
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN THOSE.
OFFENSES THAT FALL WITH THUNDER
FEDERAL REGULATION THAT EXCLUDES
FROM EMPLOYMENT BE AN
EMBEZZLEMENT PATH GRAND LARCENY.
THAT WOULD EXCLUDE THAT
INDIVIDUAL BUT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOMEONE WITH --
ES DE YOU ARE AYE OR A I DON'T
KNOW --
PETTY THEFT OR WHATEVER OUR
SOULS ARE NOT.
A QUALIFICATIONS THAT SHOULD
EXCLUDE YOU'VE I MEAN
CONVICTIONS I SHOULD EXCLUDE YOU
FROM EMPLOYMENT SO AGAIN I I I I
THINK.
IT SHOULDN'T BE MISSED ON ANY
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE OF THE
MOUNT OF OPPOSITION THAT WE HAD
IN THE SENATE AND IT'S ONLY. ONE
MAN STANDING RIGHT NOW WHO
CONTINUES TO USE THE SAME
ARGUMENT AND NOT AMENDMENT THAT
THEY ARE ASKING FOR ALL BUT GETS
THE BILL.
IT IT TAKES AWAY ANY TEETH IN
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE AND JUST AS YOU REACH
COMMON GROUND WITH OF THE CABLE
INSTITUTION WE'VE REACHED A
COMMON GROUND WITH ALL OTHER.
LENDING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS CREDIT UNIONS OF
AND THE LIKE AND AS YOU HEARD
EVEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
WILL BE REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION BECAUSE A REASONABLE
BILL THE GIVES OUR THOSE WITH
PRIOR CONVICTIONS THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR REHABILITATION
IN CHANGING THEIR LIVES IN AND
FINING FULL EMPLOYMENT.
BUT AGAIN WHAT OUT INVITE
WITHOUT VIOLATION OF THOSE%
FEDERAL LAWS IN THOSE
REQUIREMENTS THAT EXIST I
THOUGHT THAT'S THE STATE DOES
NOT PREEMPT THOSE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
THE BILL WOULD NOT DO THAT.
THOUGH IS IT.
AND MAY BACK AFTER OPPOSITION
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE.
BUT YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND PULL
THE IN HIGHER [inaudible]
RECORDS.
AFTER YOU'VE INTERVIEWED IN YOUR
SAME FEDERAL RIGHTS SO YOU CAN'T
EVEN INTERVIEW ANYBODY.
SO ANYBODY CREEK AND SO IF.
IF A HUNDRED PEOPLE APPLY FOR A
JOB YOU HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO PULL
ALL THE CRIMINAL RECORDS FOR ALL
ONE HUNDRED OF THEM BEFORE YOU
IDIOT INTERVIEW THEM.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE I JUST
NOTICED THAT SON JUST TRYING TO
YOU KNOW NOT TRYING TO GET YOU
IN A BIND OF TRYING TO GET
PROCEDURALLY NOW OBSOLETE NOW WE
DON'T DE IN MOST CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND UP UNTIL.
RIGHT BEFORE YOU PROVIDE AN
OFFER TO THE EMPLOYEE SO IT'S
DATED IT'S NOT WE DON'T PULL IT
BEFORE WE INTERVIEW THE
INDIVIDUAL.
I THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
COUPLE A DIFFERENCE THINGS
I AGREE WITH SENATOR BRADFORD
THE BILL DOESN'T.
PER HIT DOESN'T CONFLICT WITH
FEDERAL LAW AND HOW WE GO ABOUT
HIRING WHAT THE BILL SAYS IS YOU
CAN'T PULL FOR THEM CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK.
SO IF YOU.
IF YOU HAVE AN FDIC REQUIREMENT
THIS IS YOU CAN'T HIRE SOMEBODY
OF THEFT AND EMBEZZLEMENT.
HOW DO YOU GO ABOUT DISCERNING
WHETHER OR NOT THAT INDIVIDUALS
BEEN CONVICTED OF THEFT OR
EMBEZZLEMENT?
PEOPLE A BACKGROUND CHECK.
HIS BILL SAYS YOU CAN'T PULL FOR
BACKGROUND CHECK SO HOW WOULD
THE INSTITUTION KNOW THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN CONVICTED OF
A CRIME.
YOU DON'T GET YOU JUST SAY TO
THE DOJ HEY CAN I GET A CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK ONLY ON THEFT
EMBEZZLEMENT.
IS ORGAN THOUGH YOU GET THE
ENTIRE REPORT.
AND BY VIRTUE OF THAT IF FORCES
A TO THERE'S A TECHNICAL
VIOLATION THE BILL BECAUSE THE
BILL SAYS YOU CANNOT SEEK
ANYTHING BUT A BACKGROUND CHECK
FOR ONLY.
PARTICULAR CRIMES.
THAT'S NOT HOW BACKGROUND CHECKS
WORK.
SO WHY NOT JUST HAVE AN
AMENDMENT THAT ESSENTIALLY SAYS
YOUR HELD HARMLESS IS AN
INSTITUTION IF YOU PULL FOR
BACKGROUND CHECK BUT YOU CAN'T
HIRE ANYBODY.
IF THEFT EMBEZZLEMENT IS NOT ON
THE BACKGROUND CHECK.
THE REASONABLE MAN I CAN RESPOND
THAT BECAUSE I I DID EXPUNGEMENT
BILL WHEN I WAS IN THOSE SIMPLY
[inaudible]
AND AND IT WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR BUT AS WE ALL KNOW
THOSE WHO HAVE DONE EXPUNGEMENT
[inaudible]
ARE [inaudible]
OF BILLS.
EVEN THE BAND THE BOX BILLS BUT
EXPUNGE OF BILLS MORE
SPECIFICALLY WITH THIS
[inaudible]
AHA.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY WORLD
THAT WE LIVE IN WE KNOW NOTHING
IS EVER HAD.
YOU'RE GONNA FIND OUT WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO FIND OUT ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL SO IT DOESN'T PUT A
FIRE WALL UP THERE WE UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THOSE FEDERAL REGULATIONS
STATE WERE SEEN DON'T USE THOSE
BIASES?
AND I AND DISCRIMINATING AND
FROM HIRING BASED ON THOSE
CONVICTIONS THAT HAVE NOTHING TO
DO WITH THOSE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS IN THIS IS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES I THINK WE'RE TRYING.
TO MIX APPLES WITH ORANGES AND
AND CONVOLUTED THIS BECAUSE I I
I THINK IT'S STRAIGHT FOR I
THINK WE'VE LACY GOT AGREEMENT
WITH EVERYBODY.
BUT THE BANKS IN LIFE SO WE'RE
NOT HERE TO PREEMPT IN I ASKED
YOU -- TO
IGNORE FEDERAL LAW THIS IS NOT
TO AUTHORITIES LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE TO DO SUCH SHOW ON I
I THINK IT'S A STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REACH AGREEMENT WITH THOSE FOLKS
WHO HAVE BEEN WILLING TO BE OPEN.
I UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES THAT
BANKS OUT BUT I I'M I'M SOMEWHAT
SURPRISED THAT.
THE FACT THAT.
THERE CHALLENGES HERE I WITH THE
SAFEGUARDS THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
HAD HOW DO YOU ADDRESSED.
ALL THE FRAUDULENT BEHAVIORS.
OF THE BANKS OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF AYE DO YOU ADDRESS
THAT A YOU HAD THE SAFEGUARDS
HERE BUT YOU HAVE FOLKS WHO HAVE
SET UP BATTLE BREAK ACCOUNTS.
ALL OF IN THAT INDIVIDUAL'S NAME
SOUL PEOPLE'S DATA SO IT CLEARLY
SHOWS WHATEVER BACKGROUND CHECKS
YOU WERE USING.
DIDN'T DO WELL IN EMPLOYEES THAT
YOU CURRENTLY ARE WORKING IN THE
BANKING INSTITUTION --
VICE SHARE FLOOR.
YOU HAD A QUESTION.
I BUT I THINK YOU DID BEFORE I
GOT.
GOOD IN THE OF THAT --
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE COMING.
SOME IN MEMORY BUS [inaudible]
SO -- IS
THERE ARE AWAY THEN --
THAT YOU KNOW OF FOR THESE
INSTITUTIONS TO ONLY GET.
THE BACKGROUND.
DATA THAT THEY NEED.
THAT THAT IS RELEVANT TO THESE
POSITIONS TO THIS INDUSTRY.
I MEAN BY DOING BACKGROUND
CHECKS YOU WILL BUILD UP.
FIND THAT WHICH IS RELEVANT --
TO DISQUALIFYING YOU FROM I AM
BEING I'M BEEN EMPLOYED IN THE
BANKING INSTITUTION AND WILL GET
THE FULL BACKGROUND [inaudible]
I KNOW.
WHAT WERE WORSE WERE SEEN WE'RE
NOT ASKING FOR FULL BACKGROUND
CHECK BUT REALLY WHAT WE'RE
ASKING IS DON'T USE THOSE THAT
INFORMATION THAT IS NOT RELEVANT?
TO THOSE FEDERAL GUIDELINES AND
AND DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
EMPLOYEES AND WE'VE SEEN IT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN AND THAT'S ALL
WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
DON'T DISQUALIFY SOMEBODY WHO.
LIKE I SAY HEADED DO YOU LIVE
FROM BEING EMPLOYED THEY WILL
GET THEY WILL YET BE IT YES THAT
THEY'RE WITH YOU I DID THAT.
DON'T USE THAT AGAINST THEM
DON'T YET DON'T USE THAT AS THE
REASON YOU ARE NOT HIGHER.
EXACTLY THANK YOU.
YEAH I REQUEST FOR US IN THAT
SAME QUESTION TO THE OPPOSITION
AS WELL.
I I GUESS I GOT THAT'S WHAT I
UNDERSTOOD RIGHT NOW FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT THEY WERE.
THERE IS NO WAY.
THAT THEY WOULD GET THE FULL
BACKGROUND CHECKS [inaudible]
BUT THAT'S CORRECT UNDER THIS
BILL ON UNDER THE LITIGATED CASE
I WHAT THEY WANT IS TO STOP US
FROM PULLING THE FULL BACKGROUND
CHECK WE COULD ONLY PULL
PARTICULAR CONVICTION.
WE REMOVE THE WORD PARTICULAR
OUT THAT WE AMENDED THAT IT'S
STILL IN THE BILL BY --
WE WOULD APPRECIATE IT BEING
REMOVED UNDER SECTION M. OF THE
BILL.
I SAID THEY SAYS WE CAN SEEK
I'VE FROM ANY SOURCE INFORMATION
REGARDING A CRIMINAL CONVICTION
AND SAID OF A PARTICULAR
CRIMINAL CONVICTION.
WE CANNOT AMEND THE BILL IN THIS
SETTING BUT THE AUTHOR HAS SAID
THAT -- THE
BILL IS BEING AMENDED AND DOES
NOT.
PROHIBIT THE ABILITY TO GET THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS THAT ARE
NEEDED AS I STAND IT THE OUT
THERE IS SAYING THAT.
DOESN'T WANT ANYTHING THAT MIGHT
APPEAR IN THAT BACKGROUND CHECK
THAT MIGHT NOT BE RELATED TO THE
POSITION TO BE USED IN A WAY
pCANDIDATE EXACTLY I THINK THE
AUTHOR IS EMPHASIZING THAT.
AND IT HAS JUST SAID THAT ANY
LANGUAGE THAT --
MADE ANY OTHER REFERENCES SHALL
BE REMOVED --
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
UPSET I MOVE THE BILL COLLECTING
[inaudible]
THEY'RE CLOSE WE JUST NEED TO
BEAT.
MAYBE IT'S A BARRIER BETWEEN
THEM FOR FREE FEW DAYS AND THEN
COME BACK AGAIN BRIGHT FIVE I
FEEL COMFORTABLE.
THAT ONCE THEY'RE COMMUNICATING
ON THE SAME [inaudible]
PAGE.
DON'T GET THERE BECAUSE LIKE I
HEAR THEM SAYING THE SAME THING
JUST USING THEIR OWN VERNACULAR.
POLICY SO I'VE I'M MAKE A MOTION.
TWO TO DEVELOP THOSE MOVES THEIR
SECOND.
THURMOND SECOND SO I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I IT IT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AND I DO
RESPECT --
THE ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE BOTH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS MEASURE BUT I I THINK.
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE IN I
WILL STRESS SAID AGAIN THE WORK
THAT WE'VE DONE FROM THE TIME
THIS BILLORIGINATED OUT OF THE
SENATE TO WORD IS NOW.
WE MOVE MOUNTAINS AND TO THERE
JUST ONE INDIVIDUAL STE STAND IN
OUR ORGANIZATION I SHOULD SAY
THAT STANDING.
AND THE AYE BUT AGAIN IT'S IT'S
SHOULDN'T BE LOST UPON.
THIS COMMITTEE THAT THE
STANDARDS ON WHICH THEY THINK
SHOULD APPLY TO THIS BILL.
AND IF IT'S EXISTING LAWS.
IT IS FILLED MEASURE MISERABLY
AND THEM SCREENING EMPLOYEES WHO
AGAIN WITH SET UP FRAUDULENT
BANK ACCOUNTS OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS AND
PRY PEOPLE.
CROSSES NATION SO EIGHT IT
CLEARLY SHOWS WE NEED TO FIX
THIS PROCESS SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS A MOTION
A SECOND IT HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
BONTA.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE REBUS.
REVERSE AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH KNOW THAT THINGS IT
GOES OUT LANCASHIRE THINK YOU
MEMBERS.
I SEE WE HAVE SENATOR STERN WHO
WAS HERE WE WELCOME SENATOR
STERN TO PRESENT AS HE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY WELCOME CENTER.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
MEMBERS OF THE BRIEFING OVER AT
THE TAIL END YOU'RE HEARING THAT
APPRECIATED MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS --
THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
GETTING CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT TO
BE A LITTLE BIT SMARTER ABOUT
WHAT'S COMING DOWN THE PIKE
OFTEN WE JUST LOOK.
A YEAR OR TWO AHEAD BUT TO
ACTUALLY ANTICIPATED CHANGES
WERE TO SEE IN THE WORK FORCE
GOING FOR AS WE THINK WE HAVE TO
MOVE -- A
LOT FASTER IN TERMS OF OUR
ANALYSIS OF WHAT JOBS ARE GONNA
LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURETHE PACE
OF TECHNOLOGY GROWTH.
THE BENEFITS OF THAT TECHNOLOGY
BUT ALSO IMPACTS IT MAY HAVE ON
THE MIDDLE CLASS KNOWN INCOME
INEQUALITIES SO --
WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF TENSION
AROUND AUTOMATION AND IT'S BEEN
A CONSTANT SOURCE OF
CONVERSATION BUT THE GOAL I
THINK FOR ALL OF US IS
CALIFORNIA'S SHOULD BE TO GET TO
THE POINT WHERE.
WE ACTUALLY WE CAN EMBRACE
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION AND STILL
HAVE A DURABLE MIDDLE CLASS.
AND IF WE CAN FIND A WAY TO
MARRY THOSE TWO THINGS.
THAT TO ME IS A TRANSCENDENT
KIND OF PUBLIC POLICIES THAT TO
THIS BILL IS SORTED SUPPOSED TO
FORM THE THINK TANK THAT
EVENTUALLY.
WILL HELP GET THE NEXT GOVERNOR
THOSE KINDS OF IDEAS ANNOUNCES
LEGISLATURE THOSE KIND OF IDEAS.
DOESN'T REALLY PUT A THUMB ON
THE SCALE EITHER WAY BUT WE
DON'T DO LABOR DEMAND ANALYSIS
IN A SERIOUS WAY IN THIS STATE
WE DO AN ECONOMIC REPORT THAT
NONE OF US REALLY READ EVERY
YEAR BUT WE ACTUALLY WANT TO PUT
SOME OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD. TO WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE ASSEMBLY
OF THIS COMMISSION AND THAT'S
THE INTENT OF THE BILL SO.
SPEC WE ASK.
FOR THANK YOU YOU HAVE SOME
WITNESSES FOR US YEAH.
MR SHARE MEMBER SARAH FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AN
HONOR TO BE WITH YOU ALL TODAY --
SO.
WE'VE BASICALLY HAVE.
A THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
TECHNOLOGY HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BRING ENORMOUS GOOD TO MAKE WORK
SAFER TO MAKE IT MORE PRODUCTIVE
TO HAVE BENEFITS FOR SOCIETY.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT IF IT IS
LEFT UNCHECKED IT ALSO HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO EXACERBATE THE ALL
THE INJUSTICES WE SEE.
INCOME INEQUALITY WAGE
STAGNATION AND POLITICAL
POLARIZATION THAT IS DIVIDING
OUR COUNTRY.
AND SO WE DO THINK IT IS TIME
FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO LOOK AT
WHAT IS THE FUTURE OF WORK GONNA
BE WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF
TECHNOLOGY WHAT IS THE IMPACT OF
AUTOMATION ARTIFICIAL
[inaudible]
TELLIGENT.
AND WE'VE BEEN HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION WITH OUR MEMBERS
AFFECTED OUR LAST CONVENTION WE
HAD SIX HUNDRED UNION MEMBERS IN
THE RAIL.
AND WE BROUGHT UP THE QUESTION
OF HOW IS HOW IS TECHNOLOGY
IMPACTING YOU.
AND WE HEARD THAT EVERY WORKER
EVERY OCCUPATION.
EVERY INDUSTRY IS ALREADY SEEING
TECHNOLOGY.
CHANGING THEIR INDUSTRIES HAVING
AN IMPACT EVERYONE FROM HOTEL
WORKERS THAT ARE SEEING HOTELS
THAT ARE BEING DESIGNED TO BE
COMPLETELY AUTOMATED WE CHECK IN
ON A KIOSK AND YOU HAVE A LITTLE
ROBOT THAT BRINGS ROOM SERVICE
TO YOUR ROOM.
SO THERE'S NO NEED FOR FRONT
DESK WORKERS REPRESENTED BY THE
TEAMSTERS OR HOUSEKEEPERS UPPER
NEEDED REPRESENTED BY UNITE HERE.
TO ACTORS THAT ARE SEEN DIGITAL
IMAGES OF THEMSELVES
[inaudible] TO I NEED W.
WORKERS AT EIGHTEEN ANTI. TO BUY
HOSPITAL WORKERS DOCTORS AND IN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR. TWO THE FACT
THAT WE'RE USING ALGORITHMS FOR
EVERYTHING.
LOOKING OUT AT FOR EVERYTHING
FROM MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY.
TO SAYING WHAT IS THIS PERSON
SOMEONE THAT WE SHOULD SEE HOW
WE SHOULD WE SET THEIR BAIL.
AND SO ALL TECHNOLOGY IS.
THERE IS THE POSSIBILITY THAT
ROBOTS WILL BE TAKING OUR JOBS
BUT MOST LIKELY WE'RE GONNA SEE
TECHNOLOGY CHANGING THE
WORKPLACE IN VERY GRADUAL WAYS
AND WILL BE SEEING PARTS OF OUR
JOB THAT WILL BECOME AUTOMATED.
AND WE'LL BE SEEING CERTAIN TAX
THAT WILL BE AUTOMATED AND THESE
CHANGES ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
SLOWLY BUT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE A
PROFOUND IMPACT.
ON THE FUTURE OF WORK ON OUR
ECONOMY ON THE WEEK WE COLLECT
TAXES ON THE STATE AS A WHOLE.
M. AND SO WE REALLY SEE THIS
COMMISSION.
AS A WAY TO GET AHEAD OF THAT.
TO SAY THAT THE STATE HAS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE AND WE'RE GONNA
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT WE SEE
THIS COMING WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A CHANGE AND
WE ACTUALLY WE KNOW HOW TO DO
THIS.
IN FACT PEOPLE MAY NOT HAVE
HEARD BAY.
RIGHT HERE GOVERNOR BROWN HAS
ANNOUNCED THAT HE HAS CALLED THE
STATEWIDE CONFERENCE A BUSINESS
AND LABOR LEADERS TO DISCUSS THE
IMPACT OF AUTOMATION ON
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS AND ECONOMY.
HE ANNOUNCED OF THE CONFERENCE
IS GONNA BE HAD LA ON NOVEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTH AND TWENTY EIGHT
AND FOUR HUNDRED REPRESENTATIVES
OF LABOR INDUSTRY AND STATE
GOVERNMENT WILL BE INVITED AT
THE BILTMORE HOTEL.
THE QUOTE IS WE WILL EXPLORE
EVERY FACTOR INVOLVED IN
AUTOMATION TO HELP US DEVELOP
THE MEANS TO COUNTERACT ANY
ADVERSE EFFECT OF THIS
DEVELOPMENT.
OF OUR TIME.
AND THAT MAY HAVE ON OUR PEOPLE
AND OUR ECONOMY.
THE IMPACT OF AUTOMATION ON OUR
WORKERS THEIR JOB SECURITY THEIR
INCOME THEIR SKILLS THEIR
EDUCATION IS OF GREAT CONCERN TO
ALL OF US.
AND YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD
GOTTEN THE INVITATION. TO THIS
HEARING IS IS ACTUALLY FROM THE
LABOR FEDERATION.
NEWSLETTER FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE THE FIRST
GOVERNOR BROWN WHO CALLED
TOGETHER.
A CONFERENCE ON AUTOMATION WE'VE
BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
[inaudible]
AND IT.
AND BACK THEN HEME GOVERNOR
BROWN KNEW THAT WHEN YOU BRING
LABOR AND MANAGEMENT TOGETHER WE
CAN DO SOME REALLY GREAT THINGS
AND SO WE HAVE THE HOPE THAT
THIS COMMISSION WILL DO REALLY
GREAT THINGS FOR PLANNING FUTURE
WORK IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH.
YOU GOT ME I JEFF AND WAS
INVITED IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
BUT THANK YOU HOW WELL DONE --
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AFFECT TO
FOLLOW.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME'S DOUG BLOCK
PROUD TO REALLY BE REPRESENTING
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TEAMSTERS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND NEVADA.
AND CO SPONSORS ON THIS BILL.
HOW THESE ISSUES ABOUT
AUTOMATION AND TECHNOLOGY?
TOUCH EVERY INDUSTRY THAT WE
WORK AND AND THEY'RE SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR UNION THAT I'M
ACTUALLY SPENDING ABOUT HALF MY
TIME ON IT.
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS OR SO
I'VE SPOKEN THAT FOR LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS FIVE CONFERENCES I'VE
TRAVELED FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
SILICON VALLEY TO DC.
HERE I AM EVERYWHERE I GO I HEAR
TALK ABOUT THE COMING ROBOT
APOCALYPSE FOR TRANSPORTATION
WORKERS --
FOR MILLION WORKERS IN THE NEXT
FIVE TO TWENTY YEARS.
AND I HEAR DIFFERENT IDEAS ABOUT
THE PROBLEMS AND THE DIFFERENT
IDEAS ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS.
AB ONE THING I DO AGREE ON IS
I'M I'M ABSOLUTELY CONVINCED
THAT FOR EVERY JOB THAT WE DO.
THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO'S TRYING TO
THINK OF AN HAP OR A ROBOT TO
REPLACE US WITH.
BUT I DON'T ACTUALLY EXCEPT THE
ROBOT APOCALYPSE IS A GIVEN.
AND I ACTUALLY THINK THAT WE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
STARTING IN THIS BUILDING.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RETHINK%
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN WORKERS
AND TECHNOLOGY AND SPECIFICALLY
WHO BENEFITS --
JUST SAYS CORPORATIONS WOULDN'T
TRUST LABOR TO WRITE THE RULES
WE DON'T TRUST THEM.
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THIS COMMISSION AS A
PLACE WHERE ALL THE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE CAN HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE TO GET A HANDLE ON THE
PROBLEM.
LOOK AT THE PET POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS AND ADVISE YOU THE
POLICYMAKERS AND THE REGULATORS
ON HOW WE SHOULD BE MOVING
FORWARD TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL OF
US.
NOW I WILL SAY THAT.
THE TEMPTATION FOR US AND MANY
PEOPLE IN LABOR.
WOULD BE TO COME TO THIS LABOR
COMMITTEE AND ASK YOU TO JOIN UP
WITH US IN A SELF RIGHTEOUS
REVOLUTION AS WE DESTROY THE
MACHINES [inaudible]
AND NOW --
YOU REMEMBER THE LUDDITES RIGHT.
THE TEXTILE WORKERS WHO BROKE
THE MACHINES AND AND THAT.
FRANKLY SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF FUN
TO ME [inaudible]
BUT THE TEAMSTERS HAVE ACTUALLY
NEVER BEEN LUDDITES AND I WENT
BACK INTO OUR UNION'S ARCHIVES.
STARTED IN NINETEEN NO THREE
DRIVING TEAMS OF HORSES
DELIVERING MILK BREAD I A SPEAR
EVERYTHING ELSE. TEN YEARS LATER
WE SOME MOTORIZED TRUCKS GOING
TO PRODUCTION.
AND MANY PEOPLE IN OUR IN UNION
SCOFFED AT THE IDEA THAT TRUCKS
WOULD EVER REPLACE THE HORSE AND
CARRIAGE.
WE ALL ACTED IN NEW GENERAL
PRESIDENT IN NINETEEN ó SEVEN
AND HE SAW THAT TECHNOLOGY WAS
RADICALLY CHANGING OUR JOBS.
AND AS A UNION WE ADAPTED AND WE
WENT TO OUR EMPLOYERS AND WE
SAID.
THIS IS COMING YOU NEED TO TRAIN
YOU NEED TO BY TRUCKS AND TEACH
US HOW TO DRIVE THEM.
WE ARE DOING THAT AS A UNION NOW
WE'VE BEEN MEETING.
EVERYBODY FROM ROBOT
MANUFACTURERS DELIVERY ROBOTS TO
THE SCOOTER PEOPLE TO THE TRUCK
PLATOONS.
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
WE NEED YOU TO GET A SEAT AT THE
TABLE HERE.
THE LAST THING I WILL SAY IS
THAT.
I SERVE AT THE PLEASURE OF THIS
GOVERNOR ON THE COMMISSION ON
HEALTH AND SAFETY IN WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
WE HAVE EQUAL REPRESENTATION
FROM LABOR AND BUSINESS.
WE BRING AND ACADEMICS TO STUDY
THE ISSUES THAT AS THEY RELATE
TO HEALTH AND SAFETY AND REFORMS
IN THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM.
WE ADVISE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ON POLICY.
WE ENVISION THAT THIS COMMISSION
WALLS WILL PROVIDE THE SAME
FUNCTION.
AND THERE'S NO MORE CRITICAL
ISSUE OF THIS TIME THAN LOOKING
AT THE SO THANK YOU.
BAKE YOU OTHERS WHO WISH TO ADD
ON AND SUPPORT TO THE SENATOR.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF UNITED
HERE -- THE
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE AND
WAREHOUSE UNION OTHER
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
MACHINISTS ALL EXPORT MAKE YOU.
I AM BEHIND SHAKE WITH
UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL EMPLOYEES
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WERE
STUCK SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JOHN ZARRELLA WITH THE UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACTUALLY
MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION LOCAL ONE THOUSAND AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO MEMBERS
IS THAT IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PROCEED.
HERE [inaudible]
WARD CAO.
DO YOU DRAW COULD FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
NO POSITION ON THE BILL AT THIS
TIME BUT ON REVIEWING THE IN THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS WE HAVE.
CONCERNS AND THOUGHTS ON THE
COMPOSITION WORK.
CONSIDERING HOW A CURRENT AND
FUTURE AUTOMATION INNOVATION IN
THE WORKPLACE WILL AFFECT OF THE
WORKFORCE IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR MANUFACTURERS AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE RIGHT.
STAKEHOLDERS ARE AT THE TABLE
AND AWARE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHALLENGES THAT FACE OUR OUR
INDUSTRY SO WHERE WE'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND WE CAN --
ARE LOOKING FOR TO WORKING IN
THE FUTURE.
ANYONE ELSE'S CONSISTS.
ANY OPPOSITION TO ADD ON SEEING
NONE TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
THAT'S NOT AND I THINK YOU FORTY
EFFORT ACTUALLY THAT IS LONG
OVERDUE THAT WE START LOOKING IN
THE FUTURE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS IN
THE FORM OF A MAN MADE OR OR IS
A WEEKEND MAKE SURE --
WE TAKE CARE ONE THING --
YOU KNOW WHAT ONE WHEN I HEAR
THIS JUST DISCUSSION OF STEM THE
TECHNOLOGY IN THE FUTURE --
EVEN NOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SILICON VALLEY YOU DON'T SEE ANY
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO.
IN ANY MEASURABLE NUMBER --
HOPEFULLY THIS MIDDLE CLASSES
AND LIKE WHITE MIDDLE CLASS
THAT'S GONNA COME UP THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO RAISE AND THAT'S ALL
WE'RE CONCERNED WITH AS OF HIS
THE WAY WE CAN.
INCLUDE THAT.
IN YOUR ANALYSIS OF HOW WE GET
ON AFTER AMERICAN LATINOS
INVOLVED IN THIS OTHERWISE OF
BEACHES ALL WHITE NATION AND
THAT'S NOT.
GOOD FOR THE FOR THE FUTURE YOU
KNOW WHEN I WHEN I LOOK AT STAR
WARS STAR TREK IS ONLY ONE BLACK
GUY WHEN I SEE TERMINATOR
THERE'S NO.
NO BLACK PEOPLE MANLINESS
DEATHLY DIFFERS WESTWORLD IS NO
BLACK PEOPLE IN EVEN OUT A NEW
ONE TO BLACK PEOPLE ROBUST SO
THEIR SERVANTS WHO SAVED THE
WHITE PEOPLE.
SO AT SOME POINT[inaudible]
THE WE'VE GOT A IT'S YOU KNOW WE
CAN GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
TECHNOLOGY BUT I DON'T LOOK BACK
AND WE'VE LEFT A WHOLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE BEHIND.
IN ALL THOSE I'VE SEEN ANY
LATINO SO WE WON'T EVEN GO THERE
AND SO AT SOME POINT WE'VE GOT
TO JUST SAY IT.
THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY WORLD IS
LEAVING SOME PEOPLE BEHIND AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ALL INCORPORATED AND WE TALK
ABOUT HIS NEW MIDDLE CLASS THAT
INCORPORATES EVERYBODY KIND OF
GETS AWAY.
THERE AND WE CAN --
GOT OF IT WE CAN INCLUDE DAD OR
HAVE A DISCUSSION OR MAKE IT A
PART OF YOUR STUDY THAT WOULD BE
GREAT.
I SAY YES TO THAT AND I'VE
ALREADY GOT IDEAS JUST THINKING
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE IS NOT JUST
THE CONSTRUCTION OF A DURABLE
MIDDLE CLASS BUT IT'S DID LIVE
SAW COMMUNITIES OR AND SORT OF
LOOKING AT SYSTEMATIC INJUSTICE
SERVED LACK OF ACCESS TO THIS
ECONOMY SO.
NOW WORK WITH THE ON THAT AND IF
IT'S HIM IF THE CHAIRS AND THEN
WHILE I LIKE THAT IDEA SO --
YEAH THANK YOU FOR RAISING THAT.
THANK YOU SO REMEMBER KALRA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SENATOR --
AND YEAH I REALLY I CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH A SUMMER JONES SAWYER
HERBS POINT.
ANOTHER IT'S ART IMITATING LIFE
A LIFE IS IMITATING ART BUT
EITHER WAY --
IT'S NOT GOOD BUT IN TERMS WHEN
I LIVE RIGHT AND SILICON VALLEY
AND THIS SUMMER IS CORRECT --
THERE ARE FAR TOO FEW WOMEN PART
AND RIGHT IN THE SHADOWS OF OF
YOU KNOW RIGHT RIGHT IN THE
SHADOWS.
OF SOME THE WEALTHIEST COMPANIES
ON EARTH.
I MEAN YOU HAVE SOME OF THE
POOREST NEIGHBORHOODS A SILICON
VALLEY MOST GOING ABOVE.
OF LOW INCOME LATINOS ASK
AMERICANS IN AN ASIAN AMERICAN.
THIS OTHER ASIAN AMERICANS.
AND SO I'M ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT
THE HOUSE BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION --
BUT I WOULD --
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I IT'S SO
IMPORTANT.
I'M.
AND IN I'M IN A GREAT
PRESENTATION WAS ACTUALLY RIGHT
ON THE DAY OF THE CONFERENCE
UNTIL YOU'VE.
GOT ME --
HATED IT BUT OF COURSE WITH IT.
BUT THE HOME AND ANY CASE --
LOOK.
I AND I THINK IF IF TODAY'S ANY
EXAMPLE THAT WE NEED MORE AND
MORE TO BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
[inaudible]
WHAT?
HOW OUR ACTIONS OR LACK THERE OF
HAVE AN IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ON OUR WORK
FORCE?
AND I'VE BEEN TO A LOT OF
CONFERENCES CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
AUTOMATION VERY RARELY IS LABOR
AT THE TABLE.
OR PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY WORK IN
THOSE JOBS ARE GONNA BE
ELIMINATED AT THE TABLE.
IT'S MORE CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
QUICKLY AUTOMATION FOR HOW MUCH
MONEY CAN SAVE HOW YOU CAN
REDUCE GOVERNMENT REGULATION.
I GET THAT THEIR STAKEHOLDERS
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN THOSE
THINGS AND THAT'S OKAY WITH RUBY
RIDGE SAID THOSE THINGS.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE INTERESTED IN
MORE THINGS ON THAT AND AND AND
YOU KNOW AUTOMATION IS SPOKEN OF
IN TERMS OF MAKING LIFE EASIER
FOR FOLKS.
WHAT DOES MAKE LIFE A WHOLE LOT
EASIER FEET ON THE JOB?
AND SO I I AND A LOT OF
COUNTRIES DOING DIFFERENT THINGS
BECAUSE THIS KIND OF EFFICIENCY
OF PETITIONS HE BEING CREATED
THROUGH AUTOMATION TO TECHNOLOGY.
SHOULD MAKE OUR LIVES BETTER
SHOULD SERVE AS SOME COUNTRIES
AND REDUCED.
REDUCE WORK HOURS BUT DON'T
REDUCE WAGES SO YAK HAVE MORE
FREE TIME HE RIGHT BECAUSE
AUTOMATION THAT'S AUTOMATION IS.
GIVEN TO EVERYONE.
AND NOT JUST OF THE VERY FEW
THAT CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT SO
AS YOU CAN SEE YOU KNOW THAT'S
CONVERSATIONS LONG OVERDUE.
AYE IT'S BEEN HAPPY IT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IN PATCHES.
THE WAY THAT YOU INTEND AND THAT
I SUPPORT AND SO THANK YOU THANK.
FAQ ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
WE PRECIADO YOU BRING THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD --
THIS COMMITTEE ALONG WITH THE
SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE DID HOLD
THE FUTURE OF WORK.
HEARING TO DO JUSTICE --
WAS SET THE DAY GET AHEAD OF THE
ISSUE -- AS
YOU SAID IN YOUR OPENING REMARKS
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IT
GENERATES A LOT OF TENSION AND
DISCOMFORT.
BECAUSE IT'S TYPICALLY ASSUME
THAT --
IMATION MEANS A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
WILL BE PUT OUT OF WORK AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS MEASURE
SETS OUT TO SAY HOW DO WE
IMPROVE OUR LIVES AND USE
TECHNOLOGY TO DO THAT --
BUT DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE AND BRINGS ALL --
PERSPECTIVES TO THE TABLE TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AND TO PLAN
ABOUT THAT AND SO WE APPRECIATE
THE MEASUREAND WHERE IT'S
HEADED --
THAT PRE SHEET WHAT ARE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ADDED A ABOUT
THE RELATED CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE LACK OF DIVERSITY --
IN TECHNOLOGY AND THIS ARE THE
COMMITTEE HAS ALSO --
HELD A HEARING.
CHALLENGE --
THE TECH SECTOR AND OFFER HELP
TO SAY THAT --
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
WORKFORCE IS BROAD AND DIVERSE --
YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF WORK I THINK THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE A FEATURE AND
THE ABILITY TO WORK --
YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT I SEE TO
ALL OF OUR ECONOMIC MEANS ABOVE
FOR MANY OF US WORK ADDS VALUE
TO OUR LIVES THE WORK THAT WE DO
IS MEANINGFUL.
ARE TO US TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
SO I THINK THAT THEIR HEART
CONVERSATIONS AHEAD BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS A WORK
GROUP WILL BE ABLE TO HELP US BE
STRATEGIC.
AND THINK ABOUT HOW WE GET AHEAD
OF THEM HOW THOSE WHO --
MAY BE.
SOME PEOPLE MAY LOSE A CHAT WHY
SHOULD THEY BE IN A POSITION --
TO HAVE ANOTHER JOB THAT'S
RELATED TO WHAT NEW TECHNOLOGIES
ARE OFFERED WHY SHOULDN'T OUR
STUDENTS TODAY BE PREPARED AND
TRAINED. TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
TECHNOLOGY RATHER THAN BE
REPLACED BY THE TECHNOLOGY AND
MANAGED BY THE TECHNOLOGY SO I
APPRECIATE YOU THINKING FORWARD
FOR BRINGING THIS.
LEGISLATION HERE --
IT DOES HAVE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION --
BUT WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS VERY THOUGHTFUL INPUT
WHICH I INTEND TO INCORPORATE.
AND I DID WANT TO BE CLEAR YOU
KNOW -- I AM.
TALKING TO THE MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY WE ARE
TALKING TO TECH NET AND THE
TECHNOLOGY THIS THIS ISN'T.
THE LOOM BREAKING BILL RIGHT BUT
THIS IS TO SAY.
JUST AS OPPOSED TO JUST LETTING.
EMOTION DRIVE IT LET'S GET DOWN
TO THE FACTS LET'S UNDERSTAND
WHERE VULNERABILITIES ARE LET'S
UNDERSTAND WE'VE GOT A PLUG GAPS
IF THE COMMUNICATIVE SYSTEM IS.
TRAINING ONE TYPE A STUDENT BUT
WE'RE MISSING THE BOAT AND WE
REALLY SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ELSEWHERE HOW DO WE GET GOOD
DATA TO INFORM POLICY SO.
THIS IS SUPPOSE TO BE THAT TRUE
BALANCE TABLE AND IT'S NOT IN
THAT NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
CONFERENCE CALL YOU KNOW MAYBE
IT'LL HAPPEN BUT IT'S JUST.
A FEW YEARS LATER SO WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE BONTA JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE REBUS. THREE OF US AYE
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE
[inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU CAN
REGULATIONS ARE GOES OUT WE HAVE
A FEW BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL AND
MEMBERS THE THE ADD ON AND AND A
LOT OF US HAVE TO GET TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEECAN WE JUST
QUICKLY GO THROUGH THEM AND GET
EVERYBODY ADDED ON SP. THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE ON CALL HOUSE TO
APPROPRIATIONS BONTA.
KALRA [inaudible]
I YEAH AS EVER. THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE CALLER KALRA AYE REBUS.
RIVERSIDE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE HERE BELOW [inaudible]
KOMATSU.
S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY THREE BONTA
CERVANTES.
I BONTA AYE.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWELVE ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA AYE.
THIS CONCLUDES ALL OF OUR
BUSINESS <c.green> THAT WOULD BE</c>
REMISS IF WE DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
MISTER JOSHUA WHITE.
WHO IS --
BEEN SERVING US ON THE COMMITTEE
TODAY'S HIS LAST DAY WE WISH HIM
WELL OF THE BY SURE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A FEW REMARKS.
JUST THINK YOU KNOW THAT WE'VE
BEEN TOGETHER ON THIS COMMITTEE
FOR A COUPLE YEARS AND YOU'VE
ONLY LEAD ME ASTRAY LIKE TWICE
SO I THINK WE WENT KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN YOU'VE BEEN GREAT AND I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HELP IT HAS
BEEN A PRIVILEGE WORKING WITH
YOU.
SO THANK YOU.
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN SO ATTENTIVE
BUT QUITE LIKE TO HAVE A MOMENT
TO SAY SOMETHING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE YEAR
AND BEST WISHES TO YOU.
THANK YOU THIS YEAR'S AGENDA